[Applaudissements]
même si j'aime pas mais c'est quand même
bien
parce que j'aime bien les trucs qui sont
basés sur un truc et compte parce que ça
même si j'aime pas j'aime bien
si je vous dis foot
ça me dit rien du tout non on s'en foute
hein toujours du foot faudrait qu'il
nous passe un peu de sport mécanique
preuve s'il en fallait une que le foot
ne fait pas tout la fréquentation des
salles a été très bonne cette semaine
même constat côté vidéo club
[Musique]
à travailler ça a été le meilleur jour
de la semaine le jour de la diffusion du
premier match de l'équipe de France je
suis bien mieux ici que que devant la
télé très sombre on a deux télés
justement pour éviter ça comme ça on
regarde les matchs de foot d'à côté et
nous on regarde les films messieurs à
tous les blaireaux qui regardent le foot
nous on s'amuse bien bonne soirée